[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de la
semaine écoulée à l'assemblée et au
sénat avec à mes côtés tam tran huy
bonjour tam
bonjour thibault et cette semaine notre
invité est ronan dantec sénateur
écologiste de loire-atlantique bonjour à
vous bonjour et au programme de cette
émission ce feu vert de l'assemblée
nationale au budget de l'écologie un
texte qui confirme une nouvelle hausse
des taxes sur les carburants en janvier
face à la colère des gilet jaune
emmanuel macron à lâcher du lest et a
promis des mesures d'accompagnement pour
les plus fragiles 1 comment se passer du
glyphosate d'ici 2021
les nouveaux ministres de l'écologie et
de l'agriculture ont listé les obstacles
à surmonter devant les députés pour
tenir la promesse de l'exécutif à tandem
à l'unisson loin des frictions qui ont
eu raison de stéphane travert et nicolas
hulot se préparer à l'éventualité d'un
break site dur c'est l'objectif du
projet de loi adopté par le sénat
à cinq mois de la sortie du royaume uni
de l'union européenne la france se
préparent à agir par ordonnance un texte
technique et a priori consensuelle
pourtant exécutif s'est une nouvelle
fois brouillé avec la chambre est haute
et on commence par notre premier thème
la fiscalité écologique
[Musique]
rarement le budget de l'écologie aura
été à ce point au centre des débats en
examinant les crédits de la transition
écologique lundi à l'assemblée le
gouvernement a dû faire face à une vive
contestation sur les bancs de la droite
comme de la gauche
les députés de l'opposition se sont fait
le porte-voix de la grogne des français
notamment à propos de la hausse des prix
des carburants le résumé est signée
rabhi cas dans la rue comme dans
l'hémicycle la flambée du prix du
carburant est au coeur des débats les
députés de l'opposition se sont relayés
pour dénoncer cette hausse fiscale
le président de la république nous a dit
faire des choix courageux avec
l'augmentation des taxes sur le diesel
et l'essence mais où est le courage
lorsqu'on frappe ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de prendre leur
voiture qui n'ont pas de transports en
commun pas de ter
mais mesdames et messieurs les députés
de la gauche comment finance-t-on les
investissements publics les services
publics
si on n'a pas des recettes alors moi je
veux bien qu'on soit allergique à
l'impôt qu'on appelle à manifester le 17
novembre
mais à ce moment là il ne faut pas être
accro à la dépense publique on ne peut
pas en même temps être allergique aux
impôts est accro à la dépense publique
pour justifier ces hausses fiscales le
gouvernement brandit le totem de la
transition énergétique
il entend notamment financer la prime à
la conversion
plus de deux cent cinquante mille
ménages vont en bénéficier cette année
ça permet d'acquérir une voiture qui
pollue moins consomme moins qui pèse
moins sur le budget des ménages
une mesure qui ne satisfait pas
l'opposition face à la difficulté
quotidienne des français pour faire le
plein vous répondez aide à l'acquisition
de véhicules propres pour un million de
voitures au mieux sur le quinquennat
c'est bien mais vous faites quoi des 32
millions de véhicules et de voitures qui
continue à rouler l'essence et au diesel
la soeur la seule perspective que vous
offrir à leurs conducteurs
c'est de ne pas broncher et d'attendre
que le carburant soit quoi à deux euros
le litre
le gouvernement prévoit également
d'investir 350 millions d'euros dans un
plan vélo
l'une des mesures emblématiques de ce
plan la création d'un forfait mobilité
durable il permettra aux employeurs de
rembourser à leurs salariés jusqu'à 400
euros par an sur leur trajet
travail-domicile effectués à vélo aux
nantais que le gouvernement ne fait-il
pas preuve d'un certain courage en
tenant bon sur ce dossier au risque de
l'impopularité
mais est ce que tout le monde n'est pas
dans la diversion c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui monte c'est le prix du baril de
pétrole ce qui montre juste derrière
c'est la tva et la fiscalité écologique
ces quelques centimes même par rapport à
ce que l'état récupère un pas sur la
fiscalité des carburants 35 milliards la
fiscalité écologique ces 8 milliards
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne parle que de
ses 8 milliards pour qu'on ne parle pas
de de géopolitique avec ce qui se passe
en iran la montée des prix du pétrole
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se focalise sur
ces 8 milliards là vous trouvez pas
c'est un peu curieux
moi j'ai l'impression que ça arrange
tout le monde parce que du coup on ne
parle pas de la situation géopolitique
on ne parle pas des 27 autres milliards
de fiscalité sur les carburants qui
n'ont aucun lien avec la fiscalité
écologique
c'est vraiment très étrange néanmoins
néanmoins nous avions alerté le
gouvernement il y a déjà deux ans sur le
fait que cette fiscalité écologique s'il
n'y avait pas un narratif comme quoi
elle sert vers la transition
ça allait bloquer on ne s'est pas trompé
j'ai moi même au sénat si vous reprenez
l'histoire fait passer le premier
amendement qui a fait monter cette
fiscalité écologique dont je l'assumé je
continue de la défendre et je soutiens
le gouvernement quand il la défend et on
l'avait même passé avec la disette
poniatowski donc y compris avec les
républicains à l'époque et on n'est pas
très différent de la trajectoire voter
un à l'époque est soutenu aussi par
ségolène royal
donc il y avait consensus aujourd'hui ce
consensus de toute évidence s'effrite y
compris pour des raisons politiciennes
mais si ce gouvernement ne raconte pas
ce qu'il fait de ses 8 milliards pour
les mettre sur la transition écologique
et notamment sur les territoires alors
effectivement il suscite beaucoup
d'interrogations c'est il faut amorcer
sur des balances que c'est ce manque
d'explications qui explique aussi et
bien
la colère du mouvement du 17 novembre
certainement sentent monter des
territoires 1 17 novembre
incendiaire à elle risque d'une france
fracture et je crois que la france elle
est déjà fracturé c'est justement parce
qu'elle est fracturée que les s'en sert
comme souvent à deux détonateurs et de
catalyseur à ces tensions
mais il faut c'est pas la fiscalité
écologique c'est le fait
qu'effectivement on voit bien qu'on a
beaucoup de ménages en souffrance en
difficulté le reste à vivre à baisser
notamment à cause du coût du logement
ça aussi il faudrait en parler ce coût
du logement avec des gens sont partis de
plus en plus loin des centres-villes
donc se retrouve avec des mobilités
contraintes
effectivement le prix de l'essence vient
à ce moment là mais c'est une vision
globale de l'aménagement du territoire
je pense qu'à partir nous on a remis en
cause d'encadrement des loyers par
exemple ça a des conséquences sur la
mobilité sa des conséquences sur les
colères mais je trouve qu'on a on
n'arrive pas dans le moment avoir un
débat politique globale où on appréhende
l'ensemble du sujet et on se focalise
sur finalement quelques centimes de
fiscalité écologique que pensez vous des
mesures de compensation proposée par le
gouvernement est ce qu'elles sont
suffisants par exemple la prime à la
reconversion est ce qu'il n'est pas trop
faible pour que les ménages les plus
modestes puissent vraiment changer de
voiture oui moi le show que je crois
qu'il va falloir l'augmenter alors on
n'a pas une vision très très clair à ce
stade de la manière dont le gouvernement
va répondre à cette grotte moi je pense
que pour des gens en périurbain en
milieu rural qui sont dans une situation
contre ate un chèque mobilité peut se
défendre après il faut pas que ce soit
une usine à gaz que ce soit trop
compliqué moi je suis plutôt pour qu'on
accompagne un à ce stade là mais
effectivement il faut aussi aider les
territoires parce que c'est les
territoires qui finance les offres de
transports publics
or aujourd'hui la seule avancée mais
elle est réelle c'est que le ministre de
rugy sur mon interrogation 1 mardi
dernier a annoncé la mise en place de ce
groupe de travail que tous les réseaux
de collectivités demandait depuis
maintenant plusieurs années donc ça
c'est une avancée mais il faut vraiment
que les territoires soient au coeur
d'une réponse coordonnée
mais effectivement augmenté la prime à
la conversion fait partie du dispositif
alors vous parlez des petits pas du
gouvernement a effectivement
hardy le président emmanuel macron a
fait des annonces à la radio il a
annoncé un renforcement du chèque
énergie pour aider les ménages les plus
modestes à se chauffer et une
défiscalisation du chèque carburant mise
en place par certaines régions le
ministre de l'ecologie a défendu ces
mesures jeudi au sénat en marge des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
écouter le chèque énergie il marche
aussi pour 3,6 millions de français il
est augmenté l'année prochaine plus 50
euros pour atteindre 200 euros là aussi
on envisage on travaille sur un
élargissement du nombre de bénéficiaires
et puis enfin la question des transports
par la voiture pour les gros rouleurs
pour les français qui travaillent loin
de leur domicile et qui évidemment ne
l'ont pas choisie est donc là on
travaille sur un dispositif qui serait
ciblé vraiment sur ces français qui
subissent le plus fortement la hausse
des prix des carburants
ces mesures ronan dantec elles ont été
annoncées au lendemain de l'adoption du
budget écologie à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que tout ça ça ne sont pas et
bien l'improvisation la mesure de
dernière minute pour répondre à un
ajustement à la grogne et notamment une
augmentation de des taxes sur le
carburant ça va être en janvier 2010
d'affirmer en avoir de nouvelles des
mois j'avais eu l'occasion de dire à
sébastien lecornu il ya deux ans vous
allez avoir un problème
effectivement je suis assez surpris que
le gouvernement découvre le problème ce
qui est vrai c'est que comme le prix de
l'essence le prix du baril de pétrole
diminue et évidemment la montée de la
fiscalité mais pâques écologique je le
redis ne soyez pas hélas à un moment le
pétrole remonte et il va continuer de
monter ce qui veut dire aussi que les
français doivent anticiper que la
mobilité carburants fossiles
obligatoirement alwett de plus en plus
cher donc il faut effectivement à aller
dans la transition le véhicule
électrique sera dans un certain nombre
de cas aussi une des réponses donc il
faut beaucoup investir est effectivement
par exemple que les territoires qui ont
proposé une dotation climat depuis des
années proposition commune de tous les
réseaux de la mmf de france urbaine de
régions de france n'ait suscité aucune
réaction aucune réponse positive du
gouvernement
c'était c'était incompréhensible et là
maintenant effectivement un bain dans la
crise le gouvernement essaye de répondre
en urgence alors qu'il aurait pu
anticiper c'est d'éteindre l'incendié en
s'amenant voilà
tout de suite c'est bien ronan dantec
place à notre deuxième thème les débats
sur la sortie du glyphosate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sujet est politiquement très sensible
le gouvernement avait essuyé de vives
critiques pour avoir refusé d'inscrire
l'interdiction du glyphosate d'ici trois
ans dans la loi agriculture c'était l
été dernier devant la mission
d'information de l'assemblée nationale
chargé de suivre la bonne tenue de cette
promesse les nouveaux ministres de
l'écologie et de l'agriculture ont tenté
de donner des gages
mais sont ils vraiment d'accord éléments
de réponse avec clément perreault
nous allons sortir du glyphosate j'ai
pris un mois de juin un nicolas hulot
enflammé défendant la reine la sortie du
glyphosate sous trois ans devant un
stéphane travert plus froid que le
marbre du palais bourbon
les deux ministres ont quitté la scène
faisant place un nouveau duo françois de
rugy
didier guillaume cette fois promis pas
question de se tirer dans les pattes
ce jeudi matin les deux hommes étaient
entendus par la mission d'information
sur la sortie du glyphosate
l'occasion était belle d'entonner sans
modération le refrain de l'unité chez
vous et dick dans ce gouvernement n'est
pas de cacophonie mais de la
stéréophonie est donc entre nous deux
nous nous parlons en stéréo et c'est
plutôt on entend plutôt bien quand il ya
de la stéréo plutôt que de la mono en
tout cas moi je vous le dis il y aura
pas d'opposition entre didier guillaume
et moi entre l'agriculture et l'écologie
sur l'esprit de responsabilité on
pourrait se mettre d grande baffe tous
les deux très facilement mais mais et il
ya également parce qu'il est plus
costaud que moi et gagnerait mai mais
vous avez remarqué que là on n'ait pas
chacun dans notre stylo on est sur le
même bateau
merabti seulement dans la même direction
la vie des députés sur cette question et
partager je vois avec didier yom
quelqu'un qui a plaidé pour les
pesticides depuis toujours et avec très
de rugy quelqu'un qui a si souvent
changé d'avis et six qui sont à changer
de veste qu'on ne sais plus laquelle il
porte donc
réalité c'est que se retrouveront-ils au
moins sur une un sujet c'est qu'ils sont
extrêmement mobiles l'un comme l'autre
ils démarrent leur coopération
mais mais vraiment j'ai des sports et au
delà des espoirs c'est une exigence
absolue et que ce soit monsieur hulot
hier avec monsieur travers ou monsieur
de rugy aujourd'hui est monsieur
guillaume j'ai bien peur qu'il soit de
cinq exécutants de la parole
jupitérienne les deux hommes ont martelé
en choeur l'engagement du président pour
une sortie sous trois ans du glyphosate
didier guillaume avait pourtant évoqué
il ya quelques semaines une sortie d'ici
la fin du quinquennat
laissant entrevoir une certaine
souplesse dans le calendrier on en
dantec vous croyez en cette entente
cordiale affichée voir sur joué par
françois de rugy et didier guillaume
entre le ministre de l'écologie et le
ministre de l'agriculture
moi j'ai plutôt un côté saint thomas
c'était à moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on utilise moins de glyphosate en
france et que sa baisse rapidement pas
simplement dans trois ans l'inra a dit
qu'on pouvait se passer du glyphosate ça
c'est extrêmement important quand même
et je crois aussi que la stratégie qui
est la stratégie des gouvernements
depuis très très longtemps dans cette
espèce de cogestion de l'agriculture
française avec la fnsea a montré ses
limites sur les pesticides puisque
malgré le plan par exemple de stéphane
le foll sur les pesticides la quantité
utilisée a encore augmenté ces dernières
est donc là maintenant il faut
absolument que ce soit le gouvernement
qui donne le la
il ya eu tellement d'engagement sur ce
point à des manuels macron que j'imagine
difficilement que dans deux ans en ce
gouvernement dit ben non vous allez rire
on va continuer avec le diffuseur et
fausses agences dans ce gouvernement
pour sortir je pense elle est allée
évidemment il est évidemment des lobbys
je crois que les lobbys ont beaucoup
perdu avec la condamnation de monsanto
aux états unis où il ya quand même des
indemnités très très lourde mêmes
bailleurs qu'à racheter monsanto 1 voit
son action en bourse s'effondrer du fait
des indemnisations des paysans à cause
du glyphosate qui ce qui se dessine et
puis il ya d antin des atteintes à
l'environnement très fort moi j'étais
vice président de nantes métropole la
norme de potabilité eaux brutes de notre
ville est remise en cause par les par là
des g et molécules de dégradations dit
l'usaid qui s'appelle
pas donc on a un enjeu environnemental
un enjeu de santé publique
le gouvernement est allé très loin dans
l'affirmation à trois ans on en sort
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas action dans
la loi par exemple mais bien sûr je je
je le sais comme vous mais lula parce
que de didier guillon investi au manuel
de prendre ses fonctions
les réactions on peut faire de la parole
politicienne de la méfiance
moi je préfère aujourd'hui que les deux
ministres disent on va le tenir ils ont
présenté un plan c'est un changement
quand même de nature dans le fait de ne
pas dire juste la fnsea soyez gentil
baisser la quantité de pesticides
utilisés en france puisque ça ça n'a pas
marché
on a un plan l'inra dit on peut s'en
passer et donc là je serai extrêmement
vigilant effectivement par contre si les
objectifs quantitatifs ne sont pas là
sur la baisse du niveau elles l'avouent
m'entendre vous avez beaucoup parlé de
la fnsea qu'est ce que l'on peut
répondre aux agriculteurs qui craignent
et bien les distorsions de concurrence
si on les force à ne plus utiliser
moi je dispose at je les soutiens la
pression de la rue européens qui eux on
aura encore le droit on est bien
d'accord
le président république à la tribune de
l'onu a dit maintenant les grands
accords commerciaux internationaux
doivent aussi vu à l'aune des enjeux
environnementaux
le glyphosate est un exemple est-ce
qu'on va accepter d'avoir des produits
qui viennent du brésil et des produits
ogm dont l'eau gm a pour fonction
justement de permettre le traitement au
glyphosate
c'est une distorsion de concurrence donc
si la fnsea va dans ce sens là moi je la
soutiendrai tout à fait de plus en plus
de plaintes sont déposées devant les
tribunaux contre les fabricants et les
décideurs qui autorise le glyphosate
c'est une méthode que vous soutenez moi
je crois que l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui ils n'acceptent plus qu'il y
ait des épandages au bord des écoles
après près des habitations
on a eu le scandale du méthane sodium en
loire atlantique et la lanxess a réagi
très vite et on a eu un arrêt net oui un
arrêt net mais on se demande pourquoi il
a fait pour le vif ce problème avec un
des habitants touchés dans leur santé
pour arrêter alors que c'est un produit
qu'on connaît depuis très très longtemps
je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion
publique française la société française
veut sortir des pesticides veut qu'on
s'organise et effectivement les
territoires commence à s'organiser sur
le développement
du bio on est dans cette mutation
derrière c'est toute la reconquête de la
biodiversité en france parce qu'on sait
bien que c'est l'agression chimiques des
pesticides qui est la raison
fondamentale de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité des simples passereaux 1
jusqu'au moins d'eau dans notre pays
donc moi je pense qu'on est dans un
moment de transition qu'il faut
accompagner évidemment donc il faut
toujours des espaces de dialogue mais il
faut être ferme sur l'objectif final on
sort des néonicotinoïdes on sort du
glyphosate et on est dans la reconquête
de la biodiversité
allez place à notre troisième thème
l'union européenne face au brésil à
quelques mois des élections européennes
[Musique]
se préparer à l'éventualité d'un
président du rpt c'est l'objectif du
projet de loi adopté par le sénat face
au spectre d'une audi le gouvernement
mise sur l'efficacité des ordonnances ce
recours ne fait pas débat et pourtant
elle l'exécutif s'est une nouvelle fois
brouillé avec la chambre haute lors des
discussions dans l'hémicycle esti
d'aurélien romano parer à toutes les
éventualités d'un odile lors du brésil
voilà le but du texte technique sur
lequel le sénat et le gouvernement
devait forcément tomber d'accord
adopté à la quasi-unanimité son examen a
été pourtant l'occasion des échanges
houleux notamment en raison du rejet par
le gouvernement de la plupart des
amendements du sénat je suis un
rapporteur déçus et mécontents par
l'attitude du gouvernement sur un texte
qui aurait dû être consensuel jusqu'au
bout le sénat voulait préciser le texte
suivant un avis du conseil d'état que le
gouvernement a refusé de rendre public
ce qui a provoqué la colère de nombreux
sénateurs en refusant de publier l'avis
du conseil d'état
vous avez inquiéter les sénatrices et
sénateurs membres de la commission
spéciale
y aurait-il quelque chose à cacher le
gouvernement a effectivement fait le
choix de ne pas rendre public l'avis du
conseil d'état
pour la seule et unique raison que le
projet de loi touche aux relations
internationales de la france
autre point de friction le nombre
d'agents sanitaires destinés au contrôle
des produits agricoles britannique le
sénat en veut plus que le nombre fixé
par le gouvernement
et pourquoi le gouvernement en veut-il
autant au monde rural et aux
agriculteurs mais non mais vous n'aurez
pas comme ça c'est vrai quand je
caricature pas non je le caricaturent
pas c'est les négociateurs du brésil
aboutissent à un accord avant le 29 mars
le texte sera inutile est caduc le
gouvernement et le sénat se seront à
nouveau brouiller est pour rien alors
une réaction d'abord sur cette tension
dans l'hémicycle du sénat au sujet d'un
sujet pourtant constitué le rapporteur a
même dénoncé le travail de sape du
gouvernement il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord il ya le break site qui est un
enjeu majeur qui pose la question de la
place de l'europe dans le monde notre
capacité de régulation et de la
situation anglaise en particulier c'est
quand même de ça dont il faut parler un
plus que effectivement nous jeux de
rôles habituels cas sur un texte aussi
consensualité une telle opposition c'est
une m il ya quand même finalité
effectivement dans le travail
parlementaire je pense qu'on a un
gouvernement qui travaillent trop peu
avec le sénat moi je suis dans la
minorité au sénat
je ne partage pas la plupart des
amendements défendus par mes collègues
républicains tout le monde le sait mais
néanmoins je trouve qu'on a
effectivement un gouvernement qui prend
peu de propositions alors que le sénat
maintenant sénateur depuis sept ans il
cherche quand même souvent améliorer les
textes avec des propositions assez
consensuel donc ça je pense que la forme
le gouvernement quand même s'interroge
dans sa relation avec le parlement
ce déséquilibre qui existe donc ça c'est
là la deuxième question ensuite sur cet
avis du conseil d'état sur le fond je
pense qu'effectivement on est dans une
situation extrêmement complexe qu'il ne
faut pas non plus perdre de vue ce qui
s'est passé en angleterre
c'est d'ailleurs le break site c'est
d'abord une faillite du politique c'est
l'incapacité du politique à protéger sa
population
moi je crois qu'on est dans sa dans ce
moment là où quand on voit la montée des
populismes le break si tu en as été un
cas mais évidemment le brésil la
tanzanie le québec un peu partout on
voit que finalement nous avons des
gouvernements qui au nom de la bonne
santé de l'économie ne protège plus leur
population et que ça ce sont des
fractures extrêmement grave
c'est d'abord ça le break site il faut
répondre à ça aujourd'hui et les dracs
site dur ce serait très concrets de très
grandes difficultés pour les régions à
certains ports pense déjà et bien qu'ils
vont être engagées par des camions
attendant les contrôles aux frontières
ça va être un drame économique
rapidement je pense que un break 6 2
c'est d'abord un drame économique pour
pour l'angleterre ça reposera y compris
la question aussi de l'indépendance de
les causes qui se reposera certainement
derrière et puis va y avoir des
problèmes techniques ont créé dans dans
les semaines qui vont qui vont suivre
évidemment qu'on contrat mais je pense
qu'il faut quand même hiérarchiser la
difficulté majeure d'un bric site dur c
est ce que l'angleterre par exemple
devient un paradis fiscal pour sauver la
city et participe de la dérégulation du
monde bancaire
je pense qu'il faut quand même trouver
un accord avec l'angleterre pour
l'angleterre demain ne soit pas une
menace supplémentaire de dérégulation du
monde parce que plus le monde ceux des
rues des régularise plus les populismes
sont en train de monter
ronan dantec en tout cas qu'il parvienne
ou non à un accord avec la grande
bretagne
les 27 états membres bien se prépare aux
élections européennes en france le
gouvernement a d'ailleurs sorti un clip
pour inciter à voter un montage brut
anxiogène où figurent l'italien matteo
salvini également viktor orban pour la
hongrie
une vidéo très critiquée par le
président du sénat gérard larcher que
l'on écoute en utiliser le visage durban
et deux seuls vigny dans un clip sur la
participation d'abord je trouve que on a
mieux à faire un rassembler pour l'union
européenne c'est la règle et la fusée
les traités de fous ne m'apparaît pas la
meilleure manière et en plus je trouve
que c'est inutile manque iogen le clip
du gouvernement je le dénonce je suis
très clair je le dénonce
alors on en doutait qu'on entend gérard
larcher qui dénonce ceux qui parce que
c'est une utilisation partisane de fonds
publics a un petit peu oui bien sûr
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien que
emmanuel macron veut se présenter en
rempart contre les populismes mais si
j'étais un peu taquin ce qui peut
m'arriver
on aurait pu aussi mettre la photo de
renzi parce que finalement les chèques
de renzi c'est à dire le maintien d'une
politique classiquement libéral a mené
le populisme donc je ne sais pas si
manuel macron à tirer les conséquences
aussi de l'échec de mode de résine moi
moi je crois que ces questions là se
pose vraiment aujourd'hui en europe ça
doit pas non plus être un tabou c'est à
dire la montée des populismes en europe
l'avenir de l'europe
c'est le coeur du sujet mais si on ne
revient pas sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure de dire comment le politique
redevient protecteur comment les
politiques publiques protège les plus
faibles ceux qui sont justement les
moins en sécurité
et c'est pas les premières mesures du
gouvernement lisf était une erreur a
rajouté aussi de l'anxiogène donc ya pas
que le clip qui met deux l'anxiogène un
certain nombre de décisions du
gouvernement vont aussi dans ce sens là
et donc il faut que le gouvernement
entende tous les messages en entente
avec vous parler de politique française
retour finalement en france où les
relations entre l'exécutif et les
territoires restent sous tension
dans ce contexte les sénat a adopté
jeudi une proposition de loi créant
l'agencé nationale de cohésion des
territoires
son objectif mettre en place un guichet
unique pour mieux coordonner l'état et
les collectivités c'était d'ailleurs une
volonté d' emmanuel macron ronan dantec
vous faites partie des signataires de
cette proposition de loi
il faut vraiment un nouvel outil pour
permettre et bien à l'état et aux
collectivités de travailler ensemble
simplement c'est pas un nouvel arbre qui
s'ajoute dans la forêt c'était la
crainte de certains d'entre nous n'ont
d'ailleurs on a 1000 agences du
numérique il paraît qu'à le sais j'étais
dans la même structure donc on a plutôt
réduit le nombre de structures
il n'y a plus de doctrine d'aménagement
du territoire en france ça date pas de
ce gouvernement mais il n'y en a plus or
les territoires souffre vote derrière
effectivement pour les offres populiste
l'aménagement du territoire y compris
l'aménagement économique des territoires
ça doit être la priorité du politique
aujourd'hui en france donc cette cette
agence va dans ce sens là cette semaine
la maternité du blanc a fermé a été
évacué à 4 heures du matin ce qui était
là aussi une très mauvaise décision
politique
ils manifesteront à paris le 21 novembre
c'est le territoire le plus pauvres de
l'inde
on va être à une heure de la preuve de
la maternité est proche on a aussi fermé
l' agence
de pôle emploi c'est ça une des réalités
d'installation des terrils si si
l'argent qui est produit par lui
métropole et richesse produite par les
métropoles ne sont pas mieux répartie
sur les territoires si justement on n'a
pas là une stratégie très forte et ça
revient aussi sur le chèque mobilité et
sur ce qu'on a aujourd'hui comme
mobilisation contre la montée des
carburants si on ne met pas cette
question là au coeur de l'action
publique et qu'on dit effectivement le
politique est là pour protéger
alors ce pays va deux verres de grandes
difficultés merci ronan dantec merci
d'avoir été avec nous dans parlement
hebdo merci dame
merci beaucoup tu vaux merci ronan
dantec alain serrie prochaine
[Musique]